[SPEAKER_01]: Evening on the 27th of Flocktime, Jude and Horace leave the castle of the Earl of Redshore and head back into town.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, what does he think, Horace?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: An interesting man, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: It hearts a little bit to his man-at-arms.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's an old family.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I got the impression they were tied in with the Sules, the Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, apparently the Lord himself actually, some of his ancestors were, but I think they're holding on to greatness.
[SPEAKER_00]: He seems quite irritated with me when I mentioned that the poor princess
[SPEAKER_00]: The sequences, actually, especially Prince Jeon, wanted to stop slavery, but that it was Toli's.
[SPEAKER_00]: He seemed irritated with that information.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll see why.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: It sounded to me when I talked to the Earl that the entire premise of this war was to abolish slavery.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there is a war?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, most definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: He spoke emphatically that the uh... that... that... that Ernst Jeon should take uh... Coraxon seriously.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that was great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's well known that the um... the Kingdom of Keoland definitely looked unfavorably on slavery.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look unfavorably on slavery, however...
[SPEAKER_00]: What shocked me, well it didn't shock me, I took special note of, simply, was just that by his language when I talked with him alone it just seemed that he wanted to deal with the poor princes specifically, you know, Jeanne and the princess of Tips and the other poor princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he said then they would deal with Toli, but it almost sounded like he wanted to eradicate the poor princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know a little about the politics of the sea pressures.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, you must inform me.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are your thoughts here?
[SPEAKER_00]: My understanding is that, especially, I think that, alright, I've been
[SPEAKER_00]: In some considerable contact, as you might know after a year of hanging with Conmurg and perhaps with myself, we had worked under Lord Seamus, who is tied in greatly with Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: And my understanding, just personally so, is that especially Prince Jeon, the other princes have made more money since they've stopped pirating.
[SPEAKER_00]: And began in trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that they also kind of consider slavery to be somewhat onerous and unnecessary as the political ones are now gained through trade and dominance of trade rights.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the polies still have a scramble hold on slavery from the jungles in the south.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in the south,
[SPEAKER_01]: Not the Prince of Monmurg, powerful enough to stop this crisis?
[SPEAKER_00]: I am uncertain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I certain?
[SPEAKER_00]: Especially when I am uncertain of after seeing this, what hate is why Prince Siena and the Prince was tolerated abroad with any kind and not sally forth and burdened.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what troubles me too.
[SPEAKER_01]: From what I understand,
[SPEAKER_01]: The Prince of Monmurg and his fleet is powerful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably the most powerful on the Azure Sea, if not in this little day.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I am equally shocked.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the way the Bureau of Dreadshore proclaims it is there's a state of war.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not just simply embargo of certain stocks, trade stocks.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's brought out kind of cool non-embargo because of war.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are we to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we going to stay in this little fishing village?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got two options.
[SPEAKER_00]: The first is that you and I discussed before we left the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: I explained to the Earl that I was an envoy from Medhi, which very much so I am, that I was seeking
[SPEAKER_00]: He asked if I held any influence to sway over anybody, and I said simply that I would be a treaty with Laura Jamis, who is over the poor, in the same way that I gained audience with the Earl.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would hope to gain audience with Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you can tell, I love the influence.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in my discussion with him, he suggested that I should look for one individual, Owen Black, who it seems understands the photographs of both and is somewhat of a smuggling, I assume, would be premature to Europe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perhaps even higher than Europe.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, we are seeking now from this other block, and most of my understanding, if we head to any of the named Hugs, then perhaps ask, or if there's a little bit of a coin, we could probably find out who he is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Although I'm sure I am worried about bringing an assassin to old Seamus's very kill steps, so I'm not entirely sure if we do get a smuggler to guide us through.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still think that if the merchants want to go, if you take the smuggler, if he agrees, on our ship, pay the loot, and have him guide the loot through the lines.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, once we're Monmurg, I
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, do you think the man would need to have even an acquaintance with Lord Janus?
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm worried about is that we go to the Earl of Red Shorts Nightman and that he kills us and takes whatever money you have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Possibly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, Knight Man?
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the Knight Man?
[SPEAKER_01]: Knife Man?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Knight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it seems like he could have thrown us in the dungeon from here as he...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is true enough, and probably if he wanted to, taken everything on our ship as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why is it that they gave you this information?
[SPEAKER_00]: I simply entreated with him as Olemicum Idee, and when he asked who I would entreat with in Monmurg, and I said Lord Jamis was being over the Quorum Quarter, I think he was trying to enlist me as a spy.
[SPEAKER_00]: He said that he would pay handsomely for any information or insight into the mind of Lord Jamis, and by extension, Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: And furthermore, he seemed to intimate that
[SPEAKER_00]: Keoland would be better allied with Keoland than the Sea Princess.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, that was after in our conversation.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the beginning part of our conversation, he actually said that he was born when I told him about the war over the last year in Edithi.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I think that he wants to simply...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he sees me as an ugly rule.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either that or an opportunist.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe perhaps both.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's an opportunist.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, so I think I see what he's doing now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, you are a long shot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Aye, but that would assume that they're having some troubles, and apparently the Sea Princess haven't found a report, which yet, as you admitted, is a huge mystery to both of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that we have to see a port of Monmurg for ourselves, and I approach that with some trepidation.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they have troubles, we will see those troubles with dark sails in the harbor.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's my suspicion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you trust with someone black?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you trust this suggestion, or is there some other course you'd like to take?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, as I see it, we either head back to the Loot and press upon the entrance to swing around the wild seas around Chetton Island and try to approach Monomer and go south and hoping that there's no blockade in the lower bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or we slay Lord Dredshore's camp and perhaps see where it might unfold.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sentenced to
[SPEAKER_00]: Engage this old and black and find out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there's no trouble, I mean, there's no risk in meeting the man, I assume, or at least a little.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: It is as you said, if the Earl wanted to do us harm, he would have done it to us in his own castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he could have used it to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: The ship's captain to complain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, and as of yet, I think none know my capabilities.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we might, should things go south, you know, present a difficult quarry.
[SPEAKER_00]: True.
[SPEAKER_00]: As long as you keep a knife from the knife.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll cover your back, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I can inflame anything for a crop.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so we go to probably, I'm guessing, one of the finer establishments on the beach, or at least one of the ones with slightly more luxurious company.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, so you travel back to the city through the night, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And reach the outskirts of the town, which is, you know, as I've said before, obviously a fishing slash whaling town.
[SPEAKER_01]: With, you know, little use for deep docks for trading.
[SPEAKER_01]: And again, you shake your head as to wondering why somebody would think that this would match the docks of Monmurg, which are at least 20 times greater in both their efficiency and their size.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're like, wow, these toy ships probably would already have been unloaded in their cargo in the great market.
[SPEAKER_00]: In just a day.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, you walk into town, and do you want to walk alongside the shoreline, or what do you want?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd like to go inland a little bit more where I can see where you'd said that there were a lot of temporary places that are along the shoreline.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd like to see if there's more established a tavern, a bar,
[SPEAKER_00]: In which place to maybe find a smuggler?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, what it is is kind of strange because along the shoreline there are like obviously places like fish markets, stuff like that, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But many of them have kind of been converted into makeshift open-air inns.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it just seems like any old
[SPEAKER_01]: Merchants or, you know, wogues can put a keg of ale down on the beach and sell it for whatever he wants.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're like parties of people sitting around at night because there are keggers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically like teggers, with people charging you money for teggers, or even merchants just walking up and down the beach with, you know, carts with barrels of ale and so on, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Will across one of the merchants that the, perhaps like maybe some wine or something like, you know, smell like vodka, and he tried to purchase on him
[SPEAKER_00]: And make an inquiry about Stone Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you go up to one of the merchants, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just randomly, or is there any kind of look you want?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like a little bit...
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a little bit well off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mostly because since I'm dressed nicer myself, not like super noble-ish, but, you know, I'm wearing some silts and shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'll approach somebody that would seem like it'd be normal for me to approach.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so there's a guy that's kind of a cart.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he looks, what I would say is he's definitely a radian, but he looks, his clothing and dress are a little bit different than what the Red Shoreians are wearing, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: They wear very drab, kind of looking clothes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy has a little bit more finery, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he has actually two guards by his cart that seem well on, wearing breastplates and, you know, with swords on them.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have some libations, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks at you and he says, quite certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: What would you like, my friend?
[SPEAKER_01]: I have yellow wine from the Stendrip Isles, if that interests you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You look like a man of means.
[SPEAKER_00]: Most certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have recently come across from the eastern shores of the Azure, something from the west, something
[SPEAKER_00]: Global, but still exclusively.
[SPEAKER_01]: From the West.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the Stindra and Weals are from the East, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: But please, try this.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes over to a very small keg and puts a little bit of a yellow liquid in a crystal glass and says, taste it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very refreshing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's called Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I give it a sniff and hand that glass over to another one for myself, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you like your entire glass, my friend?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a silver coin per glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yes, most certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's a few silvers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely, unless he pours two of them and he goes, I must say you are my most discerning customer.
[SPEAKER_01]: He gives you music glass and says,
[SPEAKER_01]: You'd be surprised what these foolish yokels think or drink here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I must say, Cullen Moore is the most cursed lamb.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm, Cullen.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have never been here before to be fair.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm surprised that our ship was that loaded to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Quite the surprise, quite the surprise.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I was in Monmurg, I'd be selling my wares right and left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, it was forced to stop here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought I would at least try to make a little money as I were here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, these Luffians would drink fermented fish water if they could get their hands on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's done in some mare's milk.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very much so.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not dwarves.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not that bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, myself, I had brought some of the finest wine from Céline as a gift for one of my friends in Monmurg, but it seems like that too, so I'm not yet friends with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you a merchant?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nay, nay, I'm an ambassador from the, the, uh, that embattled countries, the, well, country of the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems like they have lost some of their allies in the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I've heard some rumor of the puddle wave that ravaged that post.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, much, much more, super-local.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only, uh, surpassed by the prison of the South Province and was opportunistic.
[SPEAKER_01]: I apologize for the troubles that your nation has endured.
[SPEAKER_01]: I ask, what did you come this side of the world for?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, two and three, of course, but the sequence is set for money and funds and some investment or interest that they might have.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, this tribulations follow you, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: Idean ruins and now this cursed war between the three principalities in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, I, this war, there's nothing other ways to describe it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And yet Monmurg, please, does not sally forth and destroy the Keolandish
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I look around, those just respect to any field language that might keep us in hearing, but I'm surprised that there's been no mention of any resistance from the sea princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is my mind, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll tell you, I've been here a week, seeing that this cursed war would lift, and the Monmurgans would sally forth, as you say, and yet they have not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how much longer I can wait myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is much, much.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll tell you a rumor I've heard, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it will only cost you, say, who pulls out a bottle of Chardonnay, say you purchased this bottle, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, I think that's very interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wonderful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, actually, that's not right.
[SPEAKER_01]: One gold coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he basically says there's a rumor that there's a sea monster that patrols the islands near the scimitars outside of Monmurg and that any ship from the Sea Principalities that tries to go north of the strait will be attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: Specifically the fleet.
[SPEAKER_01]: They say some sorcerer has befuddled its mind and set it against Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hence the lack of sequences breaking the block is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, like I said, it's a rumor and only true, but it's one that's been told to me several times.
[SPEAKER_00]: And to your standard,
[SPEAKER_00]: Why not have many of the merchants, Elwin's just arrived some mere six, eight hours ago and saw all these ships in the bay, that they cannot handle this level of commerce.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why not have some of them broken to go around Cessna Islands to the north and therefore perhaps avoid the seamounts or even the rumors?
[SPEAKER_00]: And pass by the Dragon Isles?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you insane?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a merchant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, from what I understand, the Dragon Isles are populated by dragon turtles that use it as basically their hunting grounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not usually dangerous, especially because the Prince of Monmurg pays them a stipend of treasure every year.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, merchants dare not go that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, of course, to the north, if we go that way, we will be escorted all the way to Gradsville.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm, yes, I simply was wondering, being uninitiated, you know, of the seas and completely ignorant of the tides, I simply look at them now and I say, well, why not go around?
[SPEAKER_00]: But, as you say, I suppose these turtles is not a problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in truth, what I was thinking is that if this deceasement lasts much longer, I will turn my ship and maybe go to Gradual to trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's tragic.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is so much crunch to be made in Monmurg, especially with a blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: True, true, but if there's a war going on and we go into Monmurg, who's to say we can get back out?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Possibly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I've heard other rumors as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to buy another bottle?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's gonna show me a couple more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You say, can I have another one of those bottles?
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, you're most generous, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm an apt listener.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, there are pirates about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pirates that do not work
[SPEAKER_01]: For the Sea Princes, but actually work for Keoland, apparently.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not two weeks ago they attacked Port Torban and burned it to the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: Port Torban?
[SPEAKER_00]: On the inner bay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yes, by the mouth of the Houle River.
[SPEAKER_01]: They destroyed the town and killed every man and woman and child
[SPEAKER_00]: I look at this man of arms.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they completely impassive?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they nodding?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or are they like they've heard the same thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, they're on guard.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're not saying anything, but it's not like they're denying this stuff with him, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're just at attention watching.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the organ is destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, and what's worse,
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a supply of food coming from the yeomanry to feed the people of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was all burnt and so the city has no supplies.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get no trade from the east and also there are pirates to the west making sure that no food rushes in.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would seem
[SPEAKER_01]: But a trifling, to my mind, to the lords of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, for some reason, the Toli are stingy with their food.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is, as I said, much decisions are... that the Toli are aligned in all lands, regardless of the hatred of each other, or the competition.
[SPEAKER_00]: Their Toli purpose.
[SPEAKER_00]: All foreigners,
[SPEAKER_01]: This is what has come to my mind as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are other strange things occurring around these lands.
[SPEAKER_00]: I come from the east and the waters of the South Province and of course aside from even just the
[SPEAKER_00]: The washing of the land with the tidal wave, it seems that things are afoot, changing rapidly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, substantially now things are changing in Selenmore as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Selenmore has been a land long thought to be lost, a land of plague from the marshes, a land of ghosts, a land of werewolves necessarily, kind of a wild land where the
[SPEAKER_01]: Rivals to the Rola, the House of Rola in Grazl, died many years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know not much about the history, but they say that the Duke of Rola has appointed a plar in the city of Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the plar means to do war with those in the marsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So war is afoot in these lands.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Hulmarshes?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Hulmarshes, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Clara has been given license to go into the Hul and attack the Flannish there.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's some religious group in that march called something like the Sons of Olan.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what I've heard lately is that the Clara has won a great victory against them.
[SPEAKER_01]: This just happened recently.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gave me a fortnight tennis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have another bottle in it?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're buying three bottles?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking for one, Owen Black, who I have heard since my arrival here might have some knowledge of the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen Black, can you describe the man to me?
[SPEAKER_01]: He sounds like a, um, he sounds like a, uh, a radian from the Outer Isles.
[SPEAKER_01]: A smuggler, eh?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you say smuggler or did you not want to say that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I did not say smuggler.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just said that he knew of the, um, the lines about the fly.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll stay by a smoker, so who wants to say that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, I think he's smart enough to kind of pick up on what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, I suggest you go to The Whale, and he points down the pier about, I would say, 200 feet, to like a place that looks pretty raucous.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are a lot of people outside it talking and so on.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: There are a lot of what I would call sailors and rogues, so to speak, from there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's what you want to find, is it not?
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe so.
[SPEAKER_00]: And your expertise, no matter how limited, but your time on these stores makes you my failure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate any suggestions that you might have.
[SPEAKER_00]: The whale, is it?
[SPEAKER_01]: The whale, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I appreciate actually your...
[SPEAKER_01]: Generosity.
[SPEAKER_01]: I must say, this was a good sale today.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fun wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have not tasted this wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're welcome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you don't want to start walking down the street, and you're basically carrying these three bottles of wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess you want to put them in your bag.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look at Horst.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you hear the microphone?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't think it was too bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said, no, it's actually very good.
[SPEAKER_01]: It didn't have any dirt in it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It didn't taste like iodide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, let's say it was very sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sweeter than my taste for most wines, but still good.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're good on me.
[SPEAKER_00]: See the weather.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys walk down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And let me check something.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have, okay, we still have seven minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm going to do after this session ends is I will just restart it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I need to log out and then log back in?
[SPEAKER_01]: You will be logged out, but then you can use the same link and it should just restart.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, well, so what I mean is that I can still stay in the game, the stone game?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the Journey of the Stone, you can definitely be in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then leave the chat open, and there'll be another prompt that shows me to click on the vision.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it'll be the same prompt.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm saying is, when I say go for it, in the Journey of the Stone, you can just bring up the link that I've already sent you, and you should be rejoined.
[SPEAKER_01]: If that doesn't work, I'll just send you a new link.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you walk down to the Whale, and it's, as the men said, I mean, it's pretty late, it's up now, it's about 10.30, but you can tell this sleepy little coastal town has a lot more people, like I said, in it, and... Yeah, it is, and there are people that are like, there are traders out there trying to trade, with a small amount of wares at all hours, there are like,
[SPEAKER_01]: You see total rats walking around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see people that like look like they're from both the Sea Principalities and Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: You also see like Keog Marines, you know like military guys that are on, that are kind of off duty.
[SPEAKER_01]: All kind of fraternizing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, you would think that actually many of these guys would be fighting if they met on the sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's like a mishmash of what's going on here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's almost like a truce of harbor or a truce of Iran?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, maybe it's that, or maybe it's that...
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there may be an understanding that since Monmurg hasn't sallied for it, there's no reciprocal state of war.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Keoghs feel like they're in control, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Monmurgians are just waiting for the stigma.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, what's happening is the Monmurgians that you're seeing here and the guys from Fort Toli, maybe they're looking for work on Keogh ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, because they don't have any work on their own.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I go in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any table to be seen?
[SPEAKER_00]: And if not, I try to get the notice of a bar matron and ask for a table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even if it's small.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, basically, this is like an open-air garage.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's basically an open place with like a covering over it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's a COVID restaurant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's exactly what it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Open to the night air.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the people are just kind of milling about.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are some like stools and seats basically made out of tree stumps or driftwood that are, you know, by the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: But for the most part people are just kind of milling around talking, you know, and carousing.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we either try to find that place where Horace and I can have a little bit of elbow room at some place, either at the bar or if there's a standing table that's just high or whatever, or if there's a regular table that we can sit for two or for four, it doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you can go around to the bar if you would like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, of course, we will.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we will order.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I don't have any glass and, you know, I'm not drinking right out of the bottle of one of my wines.
[SPEAKER_01]: My kid uses cred, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's more than one person here drinking right out of the bottle, but it's not wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look and I say, I don't see order, I think I'll take the client, but please, we need to make ourselves known here.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys go up to the bar and basically a bar date comes up and says, what can I get the two of you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I look at Boris, what would you like?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I'll have an ale.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm working glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: I actually have my own drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: I prefer to drink it out of a glass clean, preferably.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get it with no hands, no hard grip on the inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm so happy to pay for the company as this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, aren't you fancy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, unfortunately no glass here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you take a mug?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we're waiting for a friend, Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: I owe him a good amount of drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll a deception roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I'm going to go over the dice one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that a G20?
[SPEAKER_00]: G20, and let me look at your character.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't have deception skill.
[SPEAKER_00]: I traded that out for history.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's based on your charisma.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not a negative, but it's not a positive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, she says, well I know that brother, she's right over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, she's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He works with this guy that's basically over in the corner and a table with like these
[SPEAKER_01]: What looked to be like two Toli rats, you know, kind of Suel-Oeridian mix, and then somebody that looks like an Oeridian sailor as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you please give him a mug of the same thing that my friend Horace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just solve him problems with our sailor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys go and sit down.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just kind of... We just kind of wait, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's going to deliver him a drink and say compliments at our table.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just want to notice, I make sure, I mean, Horace, obviously, when she pointed and made eye contact.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so, while we're waiting, there's just the two of us, I just say, I want you to track that she's totally back from here that we're already in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's just see if he comes over a favor.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep my eye on him, then.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're about to lose each other, all right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you're going to text me go for it and then I'll click on it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll restart the meeting and then say go for it, alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: You there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Seth?
[SPEAKER_00]: You there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, can you hear it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this actually works very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can use the, uh, we can use Zoom for audio.
[SPEAKER_00]: Great.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, uh, yeah, so I just asked for it to, uh, double-check, you know, like to kind of watch his associates, since we've kind of tagged him first, so to speak, and, uh, let's see if he comes over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, I'll let, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean basically you see the serving maid go over there and put the ale down and then she pulls you out as if she's done this before, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like it's not uncommon practice.
[SPEAKER_00]: I raise my cup and acknowledge me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I'm drinking from the flagon.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does look over you and kind of sees who you are and raises his mug to you and you see him drink it down like he drinks it all.
[SPEAKER_01]: And puts it down and kind of stands up and walks over to where you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says, hey there now, I think you have me at a disadvantage, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm Owen Black, who are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: A Jew, and this is my associate's force.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please, have a seat.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm happy to buy you another drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: You come highly recommended from the highest local authority.
[SPEAKER_01]: A Jew, huh?
[SPEAKER_01]: And who would that be, might I ask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, he lives across that watery bay in that rear large construction.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, no need to speak any further.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he wouldn't send you my way unless you had requests.
[SPEAKER_00]: As it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I, I, uh, please, uh, I, I, a motion for the waitress to, the tea train is flaggin'.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get another round.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, she, she brings it over and goes, thank you kindly, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll give her a tip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure she's got, like, a few coppers, whatever seems appropriate for the, uh, area, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems like you, um, throw a coin around without much regard.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we can do business.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is it that you like?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Usually he wants a different kind of cargo delivered, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: I do come with the ship, provided that the others on board are willing to make their run.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it would be advantageous to me if they decided to make the run.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, we lose the rest of the sea is concerned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make the run?
[SPEAKER_00]: Past the sea monsters, as they say.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you misunderstand what I do, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not a pilot, per se, for hire, and I doubt there's a ship in the bay that could make the run be besides my own, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many people do you want to come with us?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you ever guide more than your own ship or simply your own ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the truth is is that my little sloop is fairly swift and I know the routes of all the patrols and I know the flags to use if you mess it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I take hands here and there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So,
[SPEAKER_01]: I think what I should say is if you want transport to where I think you want, it can't be too many people and it has to be on my ship, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: Steve, you're very saying to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: How does this sound?
[SPEAKER_00]: Better.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's better.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it would have to be two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two is very fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just the two of you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was a ship that I hoped to bring with, but it was full of merchants with starry eyes looking to make three times the profit for our charter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and that ship is traveling from Redshore to...
[SPEAKER_01]: The peninsula, if you get my meaning.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, you can only make the journey at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm, are you able to cross the bay in one single night?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me see about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Each square is 5 miles, 5, 10, 15, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, each square is 5 miles.
[SPEAKER_00]: So about 35 miles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, I can get you there by morning if you left tonight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names & A'ight, A'ight.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, that will cost you extra money if you wish to go... Names & A'ight, A'ight.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what are you charged for passengers with food?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if you wish to go tonight, it would cost you quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: 50 each, 100 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Names & A'ight.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're willing to wait a few days,
[SPEAKER_01]: It'd be less.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe fifteen, twenty, depending on how many I could muster.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not worth my time, you understand, unless there's a hundred gold coins in it for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, I certainly can understand that.
[SPEAKER_00]: When would we leave if we leave tonight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I have an hour to prepare myself, and are you docked at any place?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if we leave in an hour, I can get you to Nsar, Sennar.
[SPEAKER_01]: If that's good for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nsar?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, hanged it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: A little fishing village maybe, I would say, 30 miles from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: That sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: So for 100 gold, what he's saying is he can get me to Ensar by first time, first light roughly?
[SPEAKER_01]: Around morning time, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we would leave in an hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, can I get back to the loose and withdraw my other and or box of items from the loose?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, easily, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And get back and ready to leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: When I say, um, I always hated waiting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have your coin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Excuse me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have coin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look in my bag and I pull out the three bottles of wine and put them on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you require visual proof?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, maybe on the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, maybe 300 feet, I mean 300 yards down.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see, you see that red lantern down there?
[SPEAKER_01]: He basically points out into the night, and there's like a, a dock out there with a red lantern hanging off one of the hooks above it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, right, yes, yes, I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, do you see it, couldn't I?
[SPEAKER_01]: My sleuth is there.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's his other name?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bad luck, you see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Once you name a ship or a woman, she's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or maybe she never leaves.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got a laughter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here he goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I guess the woman never leaves.
[SPEAKER_01]: The suit goes away.
[SPEAKER_00]: By the red lantern it is in an hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, then I will make the tea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what do you do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so what I want to do is, I want to double check with Horus, what his vibes were, what he thought the Toli raps did, or the other Ovidian, you know, where they, like, did they follow us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically Horus gets back up, I mean not Horus, but Owen Black gets back up and walks back over to the table as if he was just saying hello, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you say, what about his companions, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, like I said, you know, I'll look at Horace on, like, your impressions, his companions.
[SPEAKER_01]: My impressions are the two Toli are, um, drinking partners for tonight, nothing more than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other man watched us briefly, but seemed to know what was happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably one of his crew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please make notes if you can see him again, and we will do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, God.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we're ready for the most preparing, um,
[SPEAKER_00]: Geez, I have not lived all these years in the company of guys in Colmurg, and so they have to be prepared for a school bedroom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I can hear you.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure I can loosen up walking around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's kind of faint.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you walk away, is this like a wireless headset?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'm still plugged in, but maybe it's...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think when the wire gets to a particular position, we might lose a little signal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You just told me, though, and I can adjust it on my head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's really good right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, good, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I did was that my youngest son uses these headphones, so I don't think that I actually adjusted them down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think the mic was .
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we will take a boat back to the loot in order to get the rest of our baggage and the rest of our coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys can go... No, I'm not keeping super duper tight track of my coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should I be?
[SPEAKER_00]: You said I had a... No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm keeping track of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You had about a thousand gold coins, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've taken 500 and that's 500.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I left like my wine and saline and some of the others.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ukraine and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would like to go back and check those.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, we'll have to maybe adjust the captain to set up the lightness when we get on that one there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you take the longboat crack out.
[SPEAKER_01]: That takes you about 15 minutes, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And the two of you basically get off.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to say to the longboat, then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Remain here.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will be putting our things on board, and we will be going back to shore imminently.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long?
[SPEAKER_00]: Give us 15 minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: After Rose Horace here, we'll be loading the goods on board while I saw the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I tell Horace to go ahead and unload the things, make sure he knows where the, I mean, he knows where the coinage was and stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he's like, I'll get our packs, I'll clean our rooms.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I go to talk to the captain?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the captain basically is still on deck, and I believe it's probably around 11 now.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you come, you basically come up to him and say, oh, you're back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Captain, good sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've learned quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems like no one is getting through the Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I've even heard rumors while I was on shore of some creatures in the throne.
[SPEAKER_00]: My best suggestion to you and for fellow nurses on board is to either sail here at what advantage they can or to sail mostly gradually.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's no chance this war will end?
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Poor children, by rumors, see, has been burned and raised to the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: Every man, woman and child, kid.
[SPEAKER_01]: That seems strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was it by a ground force?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I know that they're on the south side of the river.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I was just barely remembered.
[SPEAKER_00]: As well as when I discreetly inquired about traveling eastward past the Dragon Isles, but there were large sea turtles that may may since destroyed them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've spoken to a few captains.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Dragon Isles are no danger.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think no man would go within ten miles of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: But strangely enough, I talked to many of the captains and what they told me is they were hoping at some point the Monmurgans would lift the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not why.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will be disembarking here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have in good faith with my pointage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I trust that you have deserved this entirety.
[SPEAKER_00]: I seek to venture forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I will not be able to get them on there, but I can make the shore in the south and I will inquire into why sequences have allowed this blockade to hold.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I can't say this is the best news, but at least it's some news and it will help me make my decision.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you think that you will start to risk the blockade?
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, I'm on shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: As am I. Hi.
[SPEAKER_00]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was my hope to take your cargo and your merchants and see many times its value in a blockade at Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, it sounds like traveling east is perhaps not viable, and yet traveling south directly to Monmurg, it's a very narrow strait.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Keoland, if Monmurg is not out in force, and Keoland does indeed have those traits, what is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a risk I would not have to say, at least not a muscle.
[SPEAKER_00]: As an envoy from UD, I must, of course, see, by any possible way, for which I will not be able to make Monmurg on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe to the edge of the peninsula and try to fill up my land.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I must say you're very gracious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please, if you are what you say you are, ambassador, so to speak, entreat with Prince Jeon, or at least some of his advisors, to have this farce lifted.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm, I will consider.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, the very survival of Wikipedia depends upon it.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need this route open for suppliers to make it back.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no question.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, then go in peace.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Safe travels.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I hope you have safe travels yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, you know, give them a good firm handshake.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like to, as a character, just note any of the traders.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, not if there's like ten different traders, but if there's like two or three different merchants that have trade goods on the hold and the captain, then of course the name of the ship will lose.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just kind of committed some memory.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll say that if you see any of these persons, you can definitely do an in-check to see if you recognize them in the future.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's not a very difficult in-check.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it's a year from now, it might be difficult, but basically, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, just simply because, you know, if I see them at a foreign court and I need help, I might ask for it, or if I'm like, hey, if I could benefit from you shipping this there, blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_00]: For sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to make a note to the DM.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to make sure that I know faces, and kind of like what they deal in, and obviously the captain, person, person, and the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll go ahead and just, I'll make sure I see Cairo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still think that was a beautiful idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Run it up in the morning, Steve Kramer's drinking mail.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that was a beautiful idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm all like, those fuckers, I wouldn't bop to the bathroom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just counting shifts going like, this one's going to break first.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I get my goods.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everything's there, no problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: Horus is like, we got it all?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, basically it all gets loaded on the longboat.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you guys cast off from the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do you want to row directly to the port?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I would say, well, what I would say is just within like a couple, I don't know if they call it a quay, but like a pier or a couple of piers of the Sluis, so we don't need to go to the place we were last at and left from.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you can go right up to the Sluis pier itself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take a long boat and
[SPEAKER_01]: Within 15 minutes, so this is like 45 minutes after you've talked to Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we're getting close to that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: So when we get close, it's, you know, hail aboard kind of thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you come up to Dock, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And the longboat comes up next to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the guy jumps out and basically ties off the longboat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, Owen Black, who's on the other side of the pier, his ship is on the other side of the pier.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is a small ship, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, like a one-mast?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a one-mast ship, yes, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like some ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And some jibs in front, so you can navigate.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's not like a cabin in back, and it's like the stearage is actually pretty high off the ground for a ship this small, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like it's fairly fast, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a Monmurian...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is she kind of giving me the lines, like the kind of the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Does she show me it looks pretty fast?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you say, what do you think?
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, let's see whether you're up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't call it an unwellian cutter, but I think it will cut through the ocean quite fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, this man looks to be a definite blockade runner.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not in my head.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys get off and unload stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I get the look to Horace and I say, you know, we're going to make plans for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, Owen is standing there and he goes... And I'm like, drink nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about water?
[SPEAKER_00]: Unless you have it on you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, okay, I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Owen Black is like saying out of it and he goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: Come up, my friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: You come up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, and he goes, you two, help with their crates.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got a little bit of back water in my fingers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so the two of you clamber up onto the deck, and what you notice when you get up on the deck is the deck
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks strange because it looks like it's kind of been burnt.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually the mask itself looks like it has some black scorches on it as if something had burnt it in the past.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now this damage is what I would call
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, um, very, very light, and it's basically... Superficial.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's very super...
[SPEAKER_00]: Going through, but, like, just blackening bark, but not shitting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, maybe somebody dumps a bunch of burning rags on the deck, and then dumps water over it, but... Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, it's like...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a fire ship, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys get on board.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I don't know how that happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's strange to me, friend, I'll tell you a tale.
[SPEAKER_01]: This ship was stolen from me some months back, and it came back into my possession.
[SPEAKER_01]: These stars were on us afterwards.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how that happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: A benefactor?
[SPEAKER_01]: I have more than one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, I'm not.
[SPEAKER_00]: But my fault.
[SPEAKER_00]: Speaking of benefits... Great risk makes me nervous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Speaking of benefits, I have here about a typical class.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume that you would like to at least have complementary.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other half, when my feet touch dry land,
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says, that's fair enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume you do have that, though, in your possession.
[SPEAKER_00]: I kind of like shake the other coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: I make sure, sorry, I make sure that I have the 50 and 50 divided up so he's not like, you know, 50 equals 10 out of a thousand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Out of a thousand, yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I got to see that, 50, 50.
[SPEAKER_00]: I shake the one as I hand it to him, I shake the other three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll give me the coin when we get off the coast of, uh, Inksar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, provided I can swim if you throw me overboard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, don't worry, we're not gonna throw you overboard, but we're not going to dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll take a little boat to the, uh, beach and then drop you there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, okay, so, real quick notes to the DM.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I need to be dragging the donkey along on this thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, how much luggage do I have?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, you have a crate of wine and your pack and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, like, I can't, like, ask Corse to grab a fucking crate of wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, like, Enzar is a town, so if we were able to get our, like, a boat, like a longboat to shore and we unload...
[SPEAKER_00]: Right on the beach at Ensar, then all right, because we could probably get, like, a wagon or a couple of gosses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something.
[SPEAKER_01]: A mule.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: A mule.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, a mule.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay, all right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to make sure I'm not getting dropped off.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, like, having lived in Monmurg before, have I ever seen Ensar?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, is it more than just, like, a totally...
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you traveled to Port Colm,
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is to the south of Monmurg a little bit, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You've been there one time before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically to find Goug and Karmirg in one of the drunken benches where you had to pick them up because for some reason they wanted to go to Port Colm.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of those drunken horror in Port Colm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: They wanted to go to the countryside basically, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: How likely that they should be able to get a mule.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Ensar is a, you know Ensar to be a fishing village, but it's small, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: As long as it's not like, uh, Selma small.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it's Selma small, I mean, I might have a hard time, like, finding a goat.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's Selma small, but it's more concentrated.
[SPEAKER_01]: In other words, it's more like a cave junction altogether, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyway, you get on the boat, you throw him the 50 gold coins, and he says thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I take my bag and make sure he knows the weight or the sound of the coins together for the other 50.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I make sure that Horace stays awake and doesn't drink anything except for him from his own cancer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And basically, Owen Black says, where do you wish to sleep?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go below if you'd like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I won't be sleeping, just fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you welcome to stay?
[SPEAKER_00]: You are.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will be nearby.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you're welcome to stay on the steerage with me if you'd like.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I can bring you the steerage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, the sailors, and there are like maybe four guys, that's all, on the sleuth, skillfully basically take the sails, bring them up, and then the ship starts to move out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Into the bay and this, you know, maze of trading ships, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're actually a little concerned about maneuvering through this traffic.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, it's like driving through a parking lot, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where the cars are parked haphazardly in all directions, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: But Owen proves to be a very good navigator, and you're actually kind of impressed by his skill of weaving between the dozens of ships that block the bay between the island of Red Shore and the mainland.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Before long... Are we heading deeper into the bay like from that towards Angler Island?
[SPEAKER_00]: You go this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you see the red mark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I got it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically go out and by...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you got to his docks by I'd say about 12 o'clock, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So we have about a six-hour journey to get 30, 35 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, in, you're moving around, I would say, three knots as you go through the day and get you here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nautical miles?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nautical mile.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And then when you get to here, he opens it up, and actually you guys start moving around 4.5 knots.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's how it goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, let me do something.
[SPEAKER_00]: My intellect, you know, I always love learning things, so just, what I would say is it would be nice if I just noted, like, how fast can small ship with one-hand crew go?
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: You basically go out into the water and probably within the first 30 minutes you're in open sea and you see the lights of Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apparently there's another village on that island over there to the west as you start heading south.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does the blockade extend this far west into the bay?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, basically, he says, there's not much west of Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can get to Saltmarsh, but Saltmarsh, even though it does have docks, is not much of a trading town.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I hear the new lord of Saltmarsh is trying to make docks for trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the rumor about the sea monsters keeping the sea princes locked up in the straits?
[SPEAKER_00]: You heard that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, there's a pause.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did he look at least uncomfortable?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did he look on his path alive?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he looks like he's little knowing of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like it might be true?
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe, but look, he didn't really say anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're just rumors.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm driving sea turtles.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think, personally, if there is anything true to that rumor, it is one of the sea turtles from Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hence, he's dropping me up and in stock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Far west of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have gone past the Dragon Isles of Laid and I'll tell you this.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are strange storms in the sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, not long ago there was a mist that covered the bay between here and Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: It looked kind of like a hurricane, but it was too shallow a sea to be in, strangely enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I must ask your opinion, and feel free to ignore me, should your requirements as a ship's captain, and I'll force you to focus on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why has the sea princess not shattered with so landish?
[SPEAKER_00]: We all know that they could, or at least they could, a year ago, ere I left Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why are no citizen in chief?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a very large mystery.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that the rumors of the sea monster may be a bit true.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rumor is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Prince of Monmurg has not paid his yearly tribute to the Dragon Isle Dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: And hence they've allied themselves with Trolling?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're just restless, taking vengeance on the Monmurgian fleet.
[SPEAKER_00]: And perhaps Keolanders are taking advantage of that restlessness?
[SPEAKER_00]: Perhaps.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's very strange, very strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have come to entreat with the princess of Monmurg, and the sea princess, for fun and to help the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Indeed, the country that I come from, which is very big stride, I would have thought they would have easily paid any sum to the Dragon Isles, or secure trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you come to a trade with who?
[SPEAKER_00]: The sea presses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everyone knows that they have great money, and perhaps, you know, seeks to deal with endeavors.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, as having been beset by that great tidal wave a year ago, has been devastated.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the South Province has declared war on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I, your humble envoy, is coming to seek some sort of financial support and trade for whatever we may offer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, he saw it looks at you for a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, like, looks at you suspiciously, or looks at me like...
[SPEAKER_00]: Curiously.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says, I feel as if I know you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll look at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I make a roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do him in check.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a DC-15 in check.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I do a DC 20, but I gotta get over 15?
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you get your pluses for intelligence, which is plus 4.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so here we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so it's only 5.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's only 9.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look at them and I say, unless you know one gouge of karma,
[SPEAKER_00]: Names, I would not know you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Names, Do another insight roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Names, Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, Roll a 20?
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, No, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, Oh, a 20, 25 die?
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, Okay, he gets a look of fear in his eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names, Right, and he goes, for, you know, for a second, he goes, Ah, so you know, get out, Jay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's anybody who's anybody?
[SPEAKER_00]: No gals?
He said no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, you know gals.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I didn't know you were a friend of the captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that what he said, a friend of the captain?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's so shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't say friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't say that he has anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm pretty sure you felt that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, just so, just so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, well, that's interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps you can put a good word in for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, it's black.
[SPEAKER_00]: I certainly will.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said there was shipping sailing, because I've got a couple scores to settle if I'm on a personal note.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing, of course, that involves death, but good, strong crashes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess you're a more important man than I thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not going to ask me for more than 100, are you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it's good to know important man.
[SPEAKER_00]: You actually seem more important than I thought.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, working for it and working on it... As a monk.
As a monk.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, he basically kind of falls quiet at that point.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just open one of my wine bottles of Chardonnay and offer him a glass and sit from it first, of course, from the bottle before I blow him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you care to press A?
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'd sit from it first, of course, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Nuts all will pass dangerous waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically you and Horace and Owen Black, he's got his three men basically down in on the desk.
[SPEAKER_01]: You sail through the night and you don't want to sleep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Horace is alert and you guys basically just go, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so basically, are you there still?
[SPEAKER_01]: Peace.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: ... ... ...
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You there?
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, you got me now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, my son is taller than me.
[SPEAKER_00]: At 14?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, he is.
[SPEAKER_00]: 13 will be 14 in April.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he's 8th grade.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's getting ready to go into college and working at the hospital next year.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're working out.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still remember how seriously used up working out.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure I'm doing anything crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: For me, I'm just trying not to be old about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But for him, I'm just trying to get him used to like a sort of...
[SPEAKER_00]: Physical thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I've always admired how you did that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I remember, I remember you even before you were in Selma, when you were working out on that, it's a holy ghetto adventure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that was a good thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you were next to Eric Leitzer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't remember the name of that house.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't remember that house, but I remember that to me was the first time when you were like, you had like your dad to set up a pulley and just a big bench.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I was like, damn dude, I'm all fucking serious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that was good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't work out like that anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got to say, actually, I took this new job at Intel and it's been a really tough three and a half years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three years.
[SPEAKER_00]: Special packing on it when I'm here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it will.
[SPEAKER_01]: It totally will.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I'm probably right now about 20 pounds overweight.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was about 30 pounds and I never had to latch to that so maybe it was not the same.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's funny because I still go walking and stuff but I think the thing I miss the most is up until I joined Intel I was swimming quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would go swimming at least two or three times a week depending on what the deal was.
[SPEAKER_01]: We had a neighborhood pool and
[SPEAKER_01]: It was nice to be out, but, you know, it's funny because the year before I went to Intel, it just got zooed out.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was just too many people there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it got spotty.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then after I went to Intel, COVID happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: Start working from home and it was just crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still remember when you took me on, I think it was like the Greenway.
[SPEAKER_00]: It wasn't up around McTravis, but it was an accident when we went shopping and I was walking.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you were like, well, how far have you gone?
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm all like, well, how far have you gone?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're like, well, I think I've gone six miles, and I'm like, I think I've only gone six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to get back there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, hopefully I quit this job soon.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope you always.
[SPEAKER_00]: I must be happy.
[SPEAKER_00]: We got a good workout bench and the football team, Julian started on his own.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't push him.
[SPEAKER_00]: We started football in eighth grade.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he asked me why I didn't push him to do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm like, here's your mom.
[SPEAKER_00]: You would have never tolerated me pushing you for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm like, ah, okay, you didn't say anything about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: So now he had a couple friends do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so now the head of the football team for the freshman team at North Newport High School, those friends are serious.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've already been sending emails and they're like, if you play football in eighth grade, you're going to North Newport.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they've got Julian in the gym.
[SPEAKER_00]: After school, three times a week.
[SPEAKER_00]: They started out like last month.
[SPEAKER_00]: For next fall.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was like, damn, these guys are fucking serious.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got to be at that age.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, and he's going to play, you know, when we were at Ivy, Scott's going to be playing as a student.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, Jude is going to be playing Grand Bass, Roseburg, Eugene.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you still hear me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, I can still hear you.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: It sounds like he's... Actually, he likes it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, I have a four stick.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying not to be, you know, conservative.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so he acts a little bit, I mean, well not a little bit, he actually acts a little bit as he, he actually refers to Gouge as the Catholic?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to describe a little lightly around that.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at least I tried to compliment that when he said that this may be more important than he thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's where we left off, I believe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he sailed through the night, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And by, I would say dawn, you guys have made it to about there.
[SPEAKER_01]: At 10 minutes, okay, I see it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, he doesn't seem too concerned.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am concerned, but I look at him and I say, will we have a fight?
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're in the waters of the sea crunches now, and patrols never come this far.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're a small sloop.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll look like we're some kind of trading vessel from Port Jordan or what's left of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: If something needs to be done, please let me know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he keeps failing...
[SPEAKER_00]: Without, like, you know, trying to seem like a magic mirror.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, I'll, uh, I'll manibalize, uh, or, like, you know, use an arrow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: So by...
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say 8 p.m. you're there, and by 9 p.m. you're there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sailing up the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: No sign of, like, destruction, smoking villages, nothing like that?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's, you know, the coast along the peninsula of Monmurg is actually, you know, very...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of pretty.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are lots of beaches.
[SPEAKER_00]: The land up here... No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: The land up here are, like, green rolling hills.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you could see pretty far if there was any kind of like a bullet scene going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, if ENSAR was on fire, you'd see it, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, as you sailed on the coast, he goes, how close do you want me to get you to ENSAR?
[SPEAKER_01]: Shall I let you walk two miles to it?
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, two miles is fine, good man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I'm going to sail by Nsars if I was a trader and then dock off maybe in the waters six or seven miles off the coast and wait until nightfall to return to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you'll have to walk from here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two miles is completely gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would suggest you say that you come from Westkeep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, I have a Westkeep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you happen to have... We have some stuff that we cannot carry.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will unload for us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do we happen to have a handcart, perhaps?
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn, I shouldn't have heard of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I'll give you some poles that you can set the two.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two of you should be able to carry it up to the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look at me, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Doctor, I point the part from operating up to the camp.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have something with wheels?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll pay you an extra 10 gold if you can get a book and a half a mile.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, that's not fun.
[SPEAKER_01]: Villagers will see you though.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Villagers, as long as they don't compromise your credibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no care of who is an Ensar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you have no name on your ship, so nobody to complain.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he sailed you up about a half a mile from Ensar, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's obvious that... God, I'm like two miles of back in my ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, you know, as he flows the ship,
[SPEAKER_01]: So about half a mile per hour, but he doesn't stop it, and he has a couple of his men get in the longboat and take you across the water to the shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I make sure that he has the cleanage as I'm getting up into the longboat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically attach him the money as you get up onto the longboat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cast the second 50 plus 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, he'll be well in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that the only thing that I can tell the captain?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that the only thing that I can send your name with good will towards?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just remind him.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so the two of you are left on a rocky beach and basically Horace has to shoulder your crate of wine
[SPEAKER_00]: I try to help out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, did you take them up on the polls?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got some things that I don't have a minor.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna suck for me, but I can do a half a minor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I mean, you basically have these poles that have ropes on them, and you're able to put the crate between the two of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, like in a little makeshift rope net or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's only about 75 pounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I didn't come with a crap ton of stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just, like, made a change of clothes that were nice, and...
[SPEAKER_00]: Like my wine and maybe any other extra components to my spells, shit like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you guys make your way into Ensar, reaching Ensar probably after about a 15 minute walk up the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a small little fishing village and the people basically kind of look at you strangely like whoever you are, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But, you know, obviously they want to stay out of your way and do their best, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: A horse is like a burly man-at-arms.
[SPEAKER_01]: Burly man-at-arms and some strange-looking ambassador person who just got dropped off on their beach.
[SPEAKER_01]: They sort of look the other way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I go up to somebody that looks like they are not completely poor or that they have a, you know, fishing sloop or maybe no sloop.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there's a, there's a canner in town.
[SPEAKER_00]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go to the canner.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is the master around?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm he.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, thank God.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just recently run the blockade from Red Shore from a horrible hill.
[SPEAKER_00]: I seek passage to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you perhaps have a wagon, a cart with a donkey, anything that can get you to Monmurg, those tapes?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll sit again and go,
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg is 30 miles away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hi, and the donkey.
I love that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, um, Well, if you take my cart, I'll take you there for two gold coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Done.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me look it up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can check my baggage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two of you.
Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically what happens is he hooks everything up and by 11 o'clock you guys are starting to roll down the road towards Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he offer anything ahead of time?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two gold coins?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he offer a gold coin ahead of time?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to give it to him, he'll take it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd give him a gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unlike the traditional, you know, one gold on, you know, commitment, one gold on completion.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kidney, they're alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: I asked him also, yeah, how fair is the road?
[SPEAKER_00]: The war with Keoland, you know, I kind of talk all of it, like it's, you know, a big deal, and see if he's like, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, what are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you said, what about the war on Caroline?
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I assume that's the way you had to run the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Aye, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was horrendous.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was terrible.
[SPEAKER_00]: The era of the Red Shores.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg fares not very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily out here, we're making a killing off the fish that we catch.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why me traveling to Monmurg is not such a bad thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got three barrels that I can sell in the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can sell some fish.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, do you mind me asking?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen that sloop up the coast now several times.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could be the captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: He didn't really give a name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you need to know it, perfect?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not necessarily.
[SPEAKER_01]: Things are strange though.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's so stranger than being smuggled in and dropped off at Ensar, 30 miles away from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you said you were from Red Shore there, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not from Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you came from Red Shore is what you said.
[SPEAKER_00]: I came from Red Shore, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was delayed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I come from...
[SPEAKER_00]: Across the, as you see, from the ID, the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: So all I wonder is what smugglers can be operating in Red Shore that would be allowed to be there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do their alliances lie?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, don't smugglers smuggle the coin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't they all profit?
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's war?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm?
[SPEAKER_01]: This be true.
[SPEAKER_00]: I took the easiest vessel that I could.
[SPEAKER_00]: He does not follow me.
[SPEAKER_00]: He dropped me out at Ensor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should you doubt my intentions against the sea vincers, you can willingly turn me into a guard at the foreign district, and I will intrigue with Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: I request his judgment of Monmurg says.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, your mouth is full of a lot of big names.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look out my bottle of wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I open it up and I say, it should be full of a lot of names.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've had to use a lot of names to get this far.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I take a big drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks at you and he says, all right.
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he hands it back to you and he says, Now I hold you no ill well.
[SPEAKER_01]: In truth, I can't tell who is right or who is wrong in this conflict, or even whose sides do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, can you tell me why the sea princes have not shattered the Keoland fleet?
[SPEAKER_00]: As of yet, I was surprised to be waylaid, even near Redshore, as I sailed from the eastern Azure.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's my mind that Toli won't let them.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's something strange going on in the sea principalities now.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's strange storms in the bay and he points out towards Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen him on the horizon.
[SPEAKER_00]: And yet you say that Toli is somehow in control.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I can tell you is that I've seen Toli ships in between here and Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen him out there in the waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he basically points back towards this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And your hearing is about Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, well, he's a rich man and fair enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no ill will towards him.
[SPEAKER_01]: But like I say, who's going to win in this conflict?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nuns for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's something strange happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do you see that place where I put the circle?
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, do you see them islands out that way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are there actually islands in your circle?
[SPEAKER_01]: So there you can make out on the edge of your site like what looks to be like little clouds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically right on the edge of your ability to see things, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: On the waters about 12 miles is
[SPEAKER_01]: As far as you can see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, okay, so did I notice those islands when we came down to Enxar?
[SPEAKER_01]: You actually think that you might have seen some low, low, you know, there are islands out of the bay, definitely, but small ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you might have noticed some out that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he points back out.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he actually draws my attention to what maybe I had suspected was there, but we kind of skirt.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did we skirt east of those islands?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you skirted like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I was thinking.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he points out to a spot that we barely skirted, but that it actually tickles my memory of it, that maybe there were some clouds over
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, you didn't really see anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it was kind of a moonless night, so everything was kind of dark.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I look at where he's pointing and I say, well, even if those are islands in the days, what do they have to do with Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the four princes rule north.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't they?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what some say, but things are strange now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apparently, a Toli princeling took stewardship of the fort out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of those islands has a fort on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was made many years ago, maybe 150 years ago, to fight the sahaugin that infested these waters.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was a Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was a Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who said that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Who gave a Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, not Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: Money will buy anything in the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: I seek money for the war across the Azure Sea and the Iron Sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Money, however many.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I can say is I've seen ships come and go freely from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: To Ensar or some Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: All over the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And is Port Torvin truly destroyed?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Port Torvin is destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Burned to the ground by Captain Crimson.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crimson?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Captain Crimson.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he a kill lender?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or a rogue pirate?
[SPEAKER_01]: By all accounts, he's a Toli rat.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, they say he works for the commandant of this new place called Sultmarsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I offer him a kind of a slid from that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He really hasn't got work.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Steve, you're getting saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's a little better.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I offered him a drink from my newly opened bottle of Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I have two unopened bottles, just a little quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, and we drank on our way there, and if I can fly him for more information about why Monmurg has not soured for us, or about the Toli
[SPEAKER_00]: Having, yeah, the fort on those islands that he circled.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he basically said, you know, he tells you that, you know, a Toli princeling has taken residence there and has ships, several ships that sail to and from that island a lot, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he sees them actually sailing freely around in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, are they landing in Ensar, or do they have a smuggler's coat somewhere?
[SPEAKER_00]: You ask him that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, they're not smuggling.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're doing something else.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pray tell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keeping out a tight lip.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I know is when the Monmurian Navy tries to sally forth, you see ships from that island leaving the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I will pay you then, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will pay you a gold coin for his name.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_00]: If his name is Cain Zoli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he has manned to the islands in the middle of the day, south of Angra Island, north of Ansar, in the middle of the day.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do I hear you, good sir, correctly, that he, well, excuse me.
[SPEAKER_00]: That there are mysterious happenings whenever Monmurg does Sally Pore.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said Sally Pore.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Monmurgian fleet has Sally Pore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, they turned twice, aye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twice?
[SPEAKER_00]: In numbers?
[SPEAKER_01]: In numbers.
[SPEAKER_01]: The squadron.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Squadron.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what happened?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did any of the squadron return?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've heard that the squadron did return, but for some reason we're beaten off.
[SPEAKER_01]: And those same two days I've seen the fleet from Angler, I mean, not from Angler, I've seen the fleet from the port, Shelley port itself, and sailed to the east, and then a strange storm would brew.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're in the same region, just north of Monmurg, between Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: That be true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sir, I am not a captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not of the natives.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much of you say of these waters?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you hear fish deeply in the pit?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've made it to the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know the fort's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've gone that far.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to understand there's an atoll out there, rich with fish, even though there's areas where there's blight.
[SPEAKER_01]: The coral's dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can see the bones of the tahagin at the bottom of the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, this to the DNA.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, how many people are on this, uh, like, is it just me and one man?
[SPEAKER_00]: And Horton?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, just me and Horton.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will pay you to talk to Sid, Laura Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pay me to talk to Laura Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you did?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, of what you tell.
[SPEAKER_00]: I entreat thee.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will pay thee extra and ensure your faith returns.
[SPEAKER_00]: You fear not, but you must be able to communicate these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am not of the scene and I do not know of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: My patron is aware of these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: A man as powerful as Lord Jamis knows these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will
[SPEAKER_00]: He be none the less.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if he knows these things, then there is no fear for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you say, he knows these.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am a year from these shores.
[SPEAKER_00]: A year ago I had left.
[SPEAKER_00]: I returned and there was a state of war.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I am Lord Javis' man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rest assured, in having returned to these shores, I
[SPEAKER_00]: Would make certain that Lord Jamis has all information.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if he has the knowledge that you say, he would be paid nonetheless.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll tell you what.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell Lord Jamis I am loyal to Prince Jeon that I'll continue to watch.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if he wishes, he could set up a writer and I could tell him when the Toli shall it forth.
[SPEAKER_01]: In good taste, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in truth, I'm sure that a man is important and as well-connected as Lord Janus knows all that I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so to the DM, I make sure, like, you know, he's the tanner, I make sure I know his name.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to be able to tell Lord Jamis, like, exactly all the details of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so that, like, Lord Jamis knows that when I speak of it, and he says that he's like the Lord Jamis man, that this can be facilitated.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you know, I actually just hand him an extra, like, five silvers in his hand, I'd like to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: How did I not, we are all Lord Shirod's men.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys continue on.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes strangely silent.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you guys ride the rest of the way to the gates of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, these are the hour gates.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there he stops.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And says, do you have my other gold?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get him the second gold.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says,
[SPEAKER_01]: So when do you go speak to Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: I will speak to Lord Jamis as soon as he will entertain me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so this is... you get to the gates at around 6 p.m.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, takes you about 8 hours to do the trip from Ensar to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're getting there on, I would say this is 8 p.m. on the 1st of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, what I would like to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I incorrect?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jamis works late.
[SPEAKER_00]: He will always work late.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you know where his office is, and most likely he is late.
[SPEAKER_01]: He will work late.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I need to get into, at least, present to his establishment?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I need to pay anybody?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, I can enter the foreign quarter, no problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what I would do is this, is that we pay the guy, he goes back to Ensar, and I would tell Forrest, be like, nice coach, or street taxi, or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then I'll tell him to go to first.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to send him to show third.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to send Forrest to first?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's been a shitty part of town.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, like, the Boring District is not a nice part of town.
[SPEAKER_00]: Aren't we all only allowed in the Boring District?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, no, you can walk through the Great Markets.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Monmurg is basically Fort Hills, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And in the middle is the Great Markets.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's all walled.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the Porin District is a district that is kind of next to, is below the outer walls on the hills, basically on shoreline.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are docks there and so on.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then there are the great docks, which is where Lord Jamis is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Jim is as hard as I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: He controls the Docks, but also the Foreign District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he does.
[SPEAKER_01]: He controls security of both.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the Foreign District has like a main path that goes into the Great Market, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But all of the Great Market, the Foreign District, and the Harbor District are all basically not on the hills, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what I want to do is, I don't want to send horror, so it's like a, you know, a cartload of, like, 500-fold and a fucking ship that it's going to get jacked up on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if I understand Monmurg right, if it is most advantageous or most safe to just demand
[SPEAKER_00]: So the thing is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: You could probably walk through the main gates
[SPEAKER_01]: And into the Great Market and then into the Foreign District, down that main path into the Harbor area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now his office is at the end of the Harbor area in the Bailey.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what we first do is hire like a, you know, a rickshaw or something to...
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need Horace to be able to use his weapons should he have to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I suggest we stop now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know it's exciting, but I'm being a little tired, and I'm sorry... No, that's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, that's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry to slurry, and I want to be, you know...
[SPEAKER_01]: Conscious, but wouldn't we actually do this then?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like you to be conscious too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so this is a good stopping point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's stop here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right outside the gates of Monmurg at 6 p.m. and you're about to enter the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: The gates are still open if you're about to enter the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, in fact when you left last it was because karma was banished.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cooker stole the book about training dogs.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, sorry, that was actually from Greyhawk, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that was from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fucking training dogs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: If I actually get to meet Derek, I want to slap him in the face.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, I love you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you recording these?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course I'm recording all of those.
[SPEAKER_01]: Love you too, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I want to hear more about your kids.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll definitely show you some issues.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take care.
[SPEAKER_00]: Talk to you later.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will.